[Music]
the planet has been taken father the
third I came pledges eternal loyalty to
your cause except in my terms
[Music]
why by the look of it
you seem content enough at the time
refused after my planet died I had
nothing no one when I thought I never
would know is alright with that I had a
new vocation
then I found you and at my side you
became the fiercest woman in the galaxy
[Music]
that's why I chose you to find the soul
stone I'm sorry I disappointed you I am
disappointed not because you didn't find
it
because you did
and you lied I never wanted to force you
into anything
that's why
when you left me all those years ago I
allowed it you allowed it
you haven't been under the impression
you escaped
[Music]
everybody we got more deleted scenes to
break down this one all about the soul
stone so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's new infinity
war blu-ray giveaway stuff I'll explain
at the end of the video to this scene
actually goes on for quite a bit longer
but it's heard just reiterating how much
she hated her life with Thanos and him
revealing the depths of how far back
this plan went to assemble the Infinity
Gauntlet so per his conversation with
her he says that he chose her and knew
that she would become his favorite in
the one to find the soul stone or the
one that he would send to find the soul
stone because he may have understood a
little bit about the price that he would
have to pay eventually in order to wield
it so you have to imagine that in this
moment here back on her planet when he
gives her the knife perfectly balanced
is all things should be he had the idea
that she might eventually become Gamora
deadliest woman in the galaxy as we see
her in this other flashback here so even
though Gamora and present-day is saying
that that was all bullcrap and he was
making this up she never loved any of
this it's not totally true but if you're
not a big comic book reader the whole
thing about Gamora is is that she was
totally team Thanos for most of her life
until she ran into the guardians of the
galaxy the change that the movies made
is that she came to that conclusion on
her own while she was working for Thanos
eradicating all these people like when
he's asking about that random mission
that she just went on and she throws
that king's head on the floor oh he's
submitted to our Terms eventually the
idea is that she just did that all the
time
Thanos was going around from planet to
planet slow old-school style
eradicating half of the population the
gauntlet was gonna give him the ability
to do that with the snap of his fingers
so even if it had taken him another
thousand years to find the soul stone he
still would have gone around planet to
planet eradicating half of the
population that's how nuts he was the
Russos gave it this religious
connotation like he's this holy man on a
mission that's why he takes his armor
off like he can't be deterred he
believes his cause is righteous the
other thing this scene does is it adds
context to why Thanos waited so long to
get up off the chair while he was
sitting in sanctuary while all these
movies were happening to collect the
gems himself
I'm doing myself the movie doesn't
totally make it clear this scene gives
you a little more context for that
decision but the Russos said
specifically that it was because he had
to wait for the location of the soul
stone to surface that was the one thing
that he didn't know about he knew where
all the other stones were remember he
gave the mine stone to Loki to go get
the tesseract so that's why it was so
easy for him to go around and collect
all five and the soul stone was the one
that took a little bit longer because he
had set Gamora up all those years ago to
become his favorite train her to be the
finest warrior one so that she'd be
super awesome and badass but to mostly
so that she'd be able to defeat any
challenge put forth to her in order to
obtain the soul stone like vanos knew
that there was a secret treasure in a
dungeon protected by Red Skull probably
didn't know about the Red Skull part but
in every dungeon to attain that treasure
you have to beat some challenge so
that's why he trained his children to be
such badasses
he had just felt initially like Gamora
had the most potential of all his
children same deal for the rest of his
children like the Black Order training
them to be powerful enough to defeat
anyone they needed to to get their hands
on the stones when the time came to
assemble the Infinity Gauntlet
[Music]
oh you must be popular with the children
it's a simple spell but quite
unbreakable but it all just depended on
finding out where the soul stone was
there weren't any deleted scenes with
the red skull but the Russos did explain
the reason why they specifically chose
that character was one to sort of pay
off the end of Captain America First
Avenger rage esportes off into space but
also because thematically it worked with
the way they wrote the character like he
said that he was obsessed with the
stones and now he was destined never to
possess them but now he's trapped
leading others to find them like there's
some sort of divine cosmic justice in
that but of all the characters that they
could have picked and brought back to be
this ghostly aspect of death they
brought back him because he was so
obsessed with the Infinity stones in
this movie was all about the Infinity
stones
he'll probably would have been the
backup choice because she is the
mistress of death and within the MCU
specifically they say that the soul
stone controls life in death it's a
little bit different in the comics they
say that it preserves life after death
so important distinction to know I think
I did a video after the movie came out
where I explained why it's necessary
that you have all six of the gems powers
in order to be able to snap half of all
life at the same time because you get
into time-space you have to remember
that all of life was being winked out of
existence
simultaneously the only reason why you
have scenes where some characters
disappear after others like why
spider-man was the last one to disappear
is is because the Rousseau's said that
he was using his insane
spider-man levels of strength to
withstand what was happening I don't
totally buy their explanation I think it
was mostly for dramatic effect like they
wanted him to be the last one to go out
so that Tony would be left there in this
moment here but they sort of had reverse
logic when people questioned him about
it like how come it's taking so long for
this to happen because star-lord just
winked right out of existence and he's
half celestial so there you have it
that's the
explanation but don't worry there's
plenty more Marvel stuff happening and
they just dropped a whole bunch of
details about the next Batman solo movie
that's gonna happen so I'll do a Batman
video tomorrow morning there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video on name a winner when I post
new Marvel click here for that brand new
spider-man far from home teaser and
click here for that brand new venom
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody say awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]